we have a very special announcement
today
we're about to reveal who will be
joining us as a permanent host
on the talk now this person has been
doing some serious training
to get ready for their new hosting
duties take a look
[Music]
[Music]
excuse me sir jerry
hey
here we go here we go here we go hold on
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you here we go thank you
oh yeah thank you
okay
hey here it is
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
we are so excited how does it feel how
does it feel man it's um
it's really exciting first of all i want
to say you ladies have been so
welcoming to me i mean i came here as a
guest
months ago and just from the moment i
walked in you're
just gracious you're kind you're fun
and it worked and um
here we are and we're gonna have a lot
of fun we really are
we're so lucky to have you jerry we
really are
i agree and you know what jerry i told
you that's the last time you were here i
was i i just love having you on set
every day you bring such an amazing
energy
to this studio and also like i learn
from you
every day you are you are so no
seriously you're
you are an incredible uh host
and and we are so lucky to have you here
you know i have to say it's not um it's
also well
you guys are amazing there's also a lot
of people behind the cameras here
who really help out a lot you know we
have
you know everybody uh our whole crew
everybody the producers
um it's um it's a really special feeling
around here
and um and you add to that you make
everybody smile
you know names you say good morning to
everybody you know i love the fact that
wardrobe is really happy because they
got that new
thing happening with you and the
cameraman
everybody has somebody we talk we laugh
we joke
but i'm going to tell you something it's
really a two-fer we get you
but we get rebecca cause in my mind
i'm sorry no i i you know i have to say
well um
it is very exciting for me to be here in
an honor um
my wife is really excited you know
typically i'm an actor i go do a job my
wife was like okay have fun you know
you do you and um i was talking to my
wife last night and i said the big
announcement is gonna happen tomorrow
and my wife was like i'm really happy
for you this is gonna be so much
this is gonna be so much fun for you you
know i've never um
i've never done this on like a real
permanent basis you know i've done it
temporarily here and there but um
i'm really i i like to i like to have a
good time
i like to you know the world is a crazy
place
and it's scary and
it's been really scary i like everyone
else have been
cooped up you know i mean this is this
is the first time i haven't been in
underwear
in a year and a half
and i was so excited to share that with
you ladies and also with everybody
watching
we're we're going to have a good time
[Music]